Speaker 1: Speaking now on the Democratic
side, but still talking about MAGA.
There are a hell of a lot of MAGA lunatics
that really like Bobby Kennedy Jr.
Trump advisers past and present respect and
celebrate and revere.
Robert f kennedy jr.
Saying he's a patriot.
He's doing a great service to our country.
He's bringing up important issues related
to vaccines and other things.
I'm going to play a clip for you.
We will talk about whether it's a fallacy
to do guilt by association.
You all know my views about Bobby Kennedy
Jr.
Some in the audience say I'm too soft on him.
Some in the audience say I'm too hard on him.
I just call it like it is my friends.
But let's listen to what Roger Stone and Michael
Flynn and Trump's lawyer, Elina Haba and others
have to say about Bobby Kennedy.
Jr And then let's really ask ourselves the
most important question.
Why do they say these things about Bobby kennedy
Jr.
Let's listen.
Let's think.
Speaker 3: I'm a great admirer of Robert Kennedy.
He's a friend of mine.
Why?
I'm a fan of Bobby Kennedy.
So I want people to know that I actually look
at him and I think he's one of those like,
I actually have a lot in common with him because
I'm a former Democrat.
I just changed my party affiliation two years
ago.
If I were a Democrat, I'd certainly vote for
him.
If I had any money, I'd send him a contribution.
But I don't.
Speaker 7: I think RFK Jr is doing a great
service to our country.
I am disappointed that his party is so corrupted.
I mean, he's the perfect example of a true
American Democrat, a to a true patriot who
loves this country.
Speaker 3: I think he is potentially an extraordinarily
attractive candidate at the end of the day.
However, I believe that his candidacy may
serve the purpose of softening Joe Biden or
who are whoever the Democratic nominee is
for the candidacy and defeat by the man who
will clearly be, no matter what the courts
do, the Republican nominee for president,
Donald J. Trump.
I think it will help in the end soften Joe
Biden up for his defeat by Donald Trump in
the general election.
He actually has a lot of a lot of views that
are actually, I think, I think, very beneficial
across the board.
Speaker 7: I'm excited that he I mean, he's
he's shining the light inside the Democrat
Party.
Speaker 3: Robert F Kennedy Jr's campaign
is getting traction for one reason.
He's speaking truth to power.
Speaker 1: So those are all deplorable individuals.
And of course, I played this very short clip
for you last week.
Trump also singing the praises of Bobby Kennedy
Jr.
Then we'll talk about what this all means.
Speaker 3: I will say RFK Jr, who I've known
not very well, but I've known for a while
and I respect him.
A lot of people respect him.
He's got some some very important points to
be made, though.
He's a respected person.
Speaker 1: So, listen, there are two elements
to this.
There are two really important things to this.
First of all.
This.
You know, when Bobby Kennedy Jr was asked
recently about Trump supports you, what do
you think?
And he says, No, I'm proud of that.
I think that's great because we're reaching
across the aisle or whatever.
The reality is that when really deplorable
people like what you're doing, it should immediately
make you ask a two part question.
One, Are my views also deplorable?
Does the deplorable person like what I say?
Because what I say is deplorable, or does
the deplorable person like what I say or claim
to like it because I'm useful to them in some
way?
And with Bobby Kennedy Jr, the answer, sadly,
in a sense, is both.
Okay.
Now let's talk a little bit about logical
fallacies.
I did this last week.
I understand that, strictly speaking, guilt
by association is a logical fallacy.
Saying Bobby Kennedy Jr is bad because Trump
likes him.
That is guilt by association.
And strictly speaking, it is a logical fallacy.
However, we have to be able to distinguish
when guilt by association should lead us down
a path of investigation or not.
If I were to say, and I gave these examples
last week, Hitler breathes oxygen, so oxygen
is bad, that doesn't make any sense.
You say, David, sir, we need oxygen, please.
If I were to say Hitler had a doctor who drugged
him up with every drug in the world and was
just a clown.
So therefore, doctors in general can't be
trusted.
That's silly.
Wouldn't make any sense.
But if I were to say Hitler liked Mussolini
and Franco in Italy and Spain.
So that should make me skeptical of Mussolini
and Franco.
That makes sense.
However, I should still investigate it.
And I should say, Am I right to be skeptical
about Mussolini and Franco?
I would research and I would go, Yes.
Yeah.
We have looked into every aspect of Bobby
Kennedy Jr's platform or candidacy or whatever.
And of course, extraordinarily concerning
views about vaccines and autism, foreign policy,
weird statements about Russia and China, weird
China's ethnic racist bioweapon, or whatever
statements about the 2020 election, The Health
Policy Roundtable with absolute medical lunatics
on and on and on.
And when it comes to bobby kennedy Jr.
These folks like him for two different reasons.
Number one.
He shares some of their views when it comes
to things like vaccines and Russia, Ukraine
to a degree, etc..
So in a sense, there is an allegiance or a
similarity when it comes to political positions.
But in addition to that, and this is really
important to understand, Steve Bannon has
been talking up Bobby Kennedy Jr and his conspiracy
theories for a while.
Steve Bannon isn't stupid, and Steve Bannon
sees Bobby Kennedy Jr as an agent of chaos.
He can generate chaos.
He can generate chaos by potentially being
a stumbling block for Joe Biden on the path
to his renomination.
He could be a stumbling block for media that
might not be interested in a contested Democratic
primary or whatever the case may be.
This is a huge part of why these folks are
now saying Bobby Kennedy Jr.
It's absolutely great stuff.
So the more we understand about what's going
on, the more concerned it should make us.
But not just because these people like bobby
Kennedy Jr but because of the positions he
holds on many issues as I've outlined to you
over the last several weeks.